wie viel haben wir jetzt also der finale
werte darüber entscheidet wie gut diese
tschentscher wird jetzt berechnet und
zwar haben wir diesmal 123456
moschitz und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video mit eurem liebsten
zombie ich habe mir die augenringe des
todes am start und wir haben heute eine
sehr geile jump it challenge am start
von details die hatten wir auf twitter
gestellt und zwar lautet die die
mathematiker challenge am ende der runde
werden die belegten slots inventar
methode gerechnet also die belegten
slots hier mal der anzahl der tode die
ich im deathmatch bekommen habe also wie
oft ich gestorben bin der meint glaube
ich dass man möglichst wenig tode im
deathmatch haben soll
aber ich mach das anders ich sage dass
wir möglichst viele kills im deathmatch
machen sollen
also es geht darum möglichst hohen score
zu erzielen
und nochmal dieser score berechnet sich
aus dem inventar plätzen hier die belegt
sind mal kills im deathmatch und daraus
machen wir so eine community kennt also
wenn ihr das video zu ende geschaut hat
und meinen score gesehen habt dann geht
selbst mal eine doppelrunde und guck mal
welchen score ihr selbst zu erzielen
könnte die weite kommt bin mal gespannt
ob es leute gibt die weiterkommen höhere
scores kriegen wir müssen natürlich
ehrlich sein
also wenn jetzt keine ahnung
hinschreiben 2000 das colt keine ahnung
weiß nicht was jetzt so realistisch ist
jetzt noch nicht durchgerechnet dann ist
vielleicht nicht ganz so wahrscheinlich
dass man euch der glauben schenken wird
als es sollte schon realistisch sein
weswegen die community challenge
probiert es einfach mal selbst ausgeht
in jump league spielt eine runde nimmt
jedes ultimate das ist ganz ganz wichtig
denn man muss ja möglichst viele slots
belegen und hohen slot wert zu bekommen
nehmt ihr das alte mittel bekommen könnt
macht im deathmatch so viele tote wie
möglich und dann schaut mir euren wert
den ihr bekommen habt als ihr legte
inventars michaels gerechnet habt unten
rein und dann vergleichen den markt wer
bei der mathematiker challenge in
höheren wert bekommen hat ich finde es
immer gut die community auf twitter zu
fragen
und da so ein bisschen romano einzuholen
also wenn ihr zum beispiel mitbestimmen
wollt welche challengers in videos dran
kommen wenn eure fragen kommentar
angenommen werden sollen dann liegt auf
jeden fall mal auf den link in der
beschreibung der für zu meinem twitter
account und laster mal in voll oder dann
werdet ihr wenn ihr aktivitäten zur
seite nicht zu verpassen so ich hab
schon als weggeworfene schön dumm schön
dumm
das ist natürlich jetzt nicht so schlau
blöd für mich aber so ist es jetzt dafür
werde ich jetzt hier alles mit
rausnehmen
es hat noch so die alte champ mania
man ist es gewohnt an hat jetzt
natürlich eine unabhängiges gremium was
überprüfen kann ob eure scores auch
wirklich die sind die rein geschrieben
habt aber ich vertraue ich einfach mal
ich bin wirklich mal gespannt was er so
ein realistischer wert ist für also
slots sind es denn hier drei mal 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 27 4 x 4 x 9 36 slots also 36
mal gut mal die kins die man in
deathmatch macht sind dann der wert das
heißt es hängt ziemlich ziemlich stark
von den kills im deathmatch aber auch
ziemlich stark vom equipment passt dass
man mitnehmen konnte okay soweit alles
klar soweit alles radeburger sprung und
dann landen wir direkt da oben perfekt
und können sich schon das dings helfen
so dann laut blogger first first reihen
nicht durch aber vielleicht second 33 ok
jetzt die kiste luton alles mitnehmen
was über kommen könnte ich mag einfach
alles auf dem rhein
das spart mir viel arbeit ich muss jetzt
ein bisschen meinen instinkten als jump
league spieler wieder stehen die mir
halt sagen okay besseres equipment
anziehen oder inventar packen alles
andere wegschmeißen aber in dieser
challenge müssen jetzt alles sammeln
vielleicht nutze ich die zeit davon noch
mini challenge zu erklären weil dies ein
bisschen komplizierter es könnte sein
dass das manche die verständlich ganz
verstanden deswegen sage ich jetzt noch
mal die changes mathematiker challenge
und es geht darum einen möglichst hohen
wert am ende zu bekommen wie berechnet
sich der wert der wert berechnet sich
indem man die belegten inventars words
here sagt steigt mit der anzahl der
kills die man im deathmatch gemacht hat
mal nimmt
je höher dieser wert desto besser so
jetzt muss ein jeder verstanden haben
glaube ich oder gut also weiter im text
hier wo gott dass da hinten ist eine
richtige abfahrt das habe ich bisher nur
einmal gespielt und nicht geschafft muss
man eigentlich außen dran
muss man da rein ich glaube man muss da
rein
okay vielleicht dahin ja so gut und dann
wahrscheinlich darunter alt hat aber
einiges gefehlt hat direkt aufspringen
gerade jetzt wenn ich hier direkt da
unten bin dann kann ich drauf okay nice
so geht's okay wir haben nur noch 34
sekunden aber vielleicht finden wir hier
nochmal die chest so weit war ich noch
nie
diese module okay das ist sehr geil das
ist gar nicht so schwierig man einfach
alles mitnehmen kommt vielleicht können
wir dass da hinten mit dem wir uns jetzt
klick machen alter ortner soll die kiste
kommen auch noch mitnehmen
sehr geil okay noch eine sekunde
montierte finnischen können okay jetzt
haben wir unser inventar sports ich
werde jetzt hier einfach mal die rüstung
austauschen sagt und jetzt wollt ihr
denn hier weg nutzen dabei darauf achten
dass ich vielleicht nicht die wand werde
natürlich zu relativ gleich oder thomas
mathenia ja komm schon okay aber sehr
gut gut erster kill ist gemacht so sehr
gut wir müssen zeit auf max kills gehen
also keine pause zack slots sind da
alles da
tnt ist da leute sogar das tnt kam jetzt
wehtun bei dem bei dem weder der wertung
am ende weil je weniger tnt ich hab bzw
wenn ich am ende gar kein thema hat ist
natürlich auch schlecht für mich weil
dann der slot nicht mehr belegt ist so
den habe mir geholt zwei kids alles da
ich stoff ist auch vorab ist mir
komplett egal jetzt auf diese runde geht
einfach auf maximale kiss so drei kids
gut auf ihnen da kommt bleibt stehen
d'amico bleibt stimmbänder hoch und
kommen sie mal vierter kill kommt für
takyi baby machen die keine faxen
ich werde halt auch nicht ewig folgen
kommt kämpft gegen mich kämpfen gegen
mich kämpfen gegen nicht ich wusste es
junge komm jetzt so jung ist kann ich
mir nicht antun
ich brauche jetzt auf den nächsten egal
egal alles gut da okay das ist einfach
der mediabus problem
jetzt ist er wieder da kann ich mich
hiermit geben ich kann dem hit geben
dass man für ca nein nein nein macht
denn ich mache das nicht okay tnt
einsätzen vor mich setzen sich beide
gesetzt beide gehen in sein gesicht ok
pfeil vier kills habe ich vier clips
habe ich den 15 5 er hat deshalb das low
life as [ __ ] okay ich hab den kiel
bekommen 1951 die greifen sich nicht an
to be one sehr schön finde ich sehr gut
hier kann ich das abstauben kann ich
locker sechster siebter kill sehr schön
wunderbar auf der hand nach dem
maximalen wert oh gott
aber der hat so richtig zug mit den hole
ich mir so nicht mehr weg sonst nämlich
ja dann habe ich den habe ich okay auf
dem weg zum achten leute auf dem weg zum
achten kiel kamen scheinen kaum schon
kommt schon okay jetzt abmarsch weg mit
dir das ist der artikel erfolgt aus der
map raus müsste als meiner gezählt
werden und es zählt als meiner sehr
schön die fiktiven und da vorne ist
eventuell meinen neuen paket gehört
haben schon angst vor mir die laufen
schon weg selbst der typ mit dem die
akkus das gute ist der diabetes typ hat
keinen kiel bekommen heißt er hat auch
keine region heißt wiederum low life as
[ __ ] wahrscheinlich und wenn der anderen
jetzt nicht der ein gerät weg job weg
von meinem weg von meinem kill du nein
der andere nach der anderen auf märz
macht er wieder die abfahrt ski
challenge und vermied da hinten ist der
andere des lola auf jeden fall ich muss
auf denen dann gehen für meinen neuen
brauch maximal hohen wert angeben auf
denen der hat noch ein leben beide haben
noch ein leben das ich kann maximal noch
zehn kills rausholen dieser runde was
ein guter wert wäre
sag ich mal neu pakistan so und jetzt wo
es mal zehn tage fliegt raus heißt aber
auch dass niemand seine rückkehr also er
hat schon zombie fleisch gegessen es
pausen der macht auf jeden fall kein
kind dieser rolle mehr
damit habe ich zehn kilo wir rechnen aus
wie viel haben wir jetzt also der finale
werte darüber entscheidet wie gut diese
tschentscher wird jetzt berechnet und
zwar haben wir zehn mal 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 12
3 4 5 6 7 8 also 20 + 7 27 damit der
mathematiker challenge einen wert von
jetzt geht es an euch geht die public
runden macht screenshots von eurer and
statistik sowie die hier
dazu noch ein screenshot von eurem
inventar und postet die in youtube
kommentaren oder als antwort an mich auf
twitter und dann sehen wir mal wer bei
dieser kälte besser abgeschnitten hat
ach ja und übrigens der beste skorer der
belegt wird mit screenshots trägt von
mir in erwähnung im nächsten video also
haltet euch ran das war so weit von mir
ich bin gespannt auf eure einsendungen
bis dann haut rein macht's gut und tja